did you see that tick tock of angus
praising your men's health cover
i've never seen a tick tock the only
tick tock i ever saw was like this
golden retriever stealing um
like these crackers
is gassing you up he thinks you look
good on that cover yeah he's like the
kindest human on the planet he's got a
heart of gold and now he's in that jack
harlow song
come on now i don't even know what that
means but that's that's awesome i like
jack holler that's nice he's a big angus
clown fan apparently he name checked him
in a song first class damn there you go
this isn't about being a good person
cassie or being a good friend this is
about you getting what you want
how often do you get that people coming
up to you and say you're so much nicer
in person
not often i'm a bit of a
i find that hard to believe jacob i do
oh my gosh not not at the academy museum
television
listen i mean we still can't get over
that season finale please tell me we
don't have to wait until 2024 for season
three what do you know no you might have
to wait
ten years
it takes a long time no i don't know i
think it's 20 25 i'm not sure do you
appreciate that break though especially
coming out of a character like that
um
yeah yeah it's nice it's nice to take a
breath but also you know like it's such
a joy being there i could i could be
there for the rest of my life you know
it's enjoyable well talk to me about the
bond you guys have created off the set
we're all just great mates and you know
when you work with people creatively
like that
it's hard not to have
you know that kind of connection with
everybody you know you're
it's like divulging your deepest darkest
secrets with everyone all the time
everyone's burying themselves and
putting themselves on the line you know
[Music]
you